20:19 is behind us what am I looking
forward to in 2020 all right I do like
in the early days of the new year to
talk about what movies are coming out
that I think look good and have me
genuinely excited it's not actually ten
because I limit this list of movies that
I am genuinely excited for not just ones
that I am hopeful for or like have a
general interest in I plan to see more
movies in the what I'm gonna talk than
the ones I'm gonna talk about but these
ones are the ones that I have reason to
be genuinely pumped to see so I have got
eight on this list for varying reasons
and we'll get into why and these are not
in order of you know least to most
anticipate it I'm actually doing these
in the order that they're being released
throughout the year so chronological
list assuming the release dates don't
get changed we just happened to me
before
so first up Black Widow I love this
character and I thought the trailer
looked really good it looks like it's
the scale that I want it to be it is an
espionage personal story which is the
kind of cleanser we need after endgame
which was so friggin huge and this is
it's just really the good way to do it
some could argue that spider-man apart
from home
what's the palate cleanser except I was
kind of let down by spider-man far far
from home so I still kind of need
something serve as that and I think this
is a pretty good chance of doing that
after that we've got Wonder Woman
1984 Wonder Woman is a movie with some
really good elements and a couple of
amazing scenes but also some clunky
moments and a third act that's a little
not bad just slightly generic and I
really want to see what 1984 will be to
see them build on that to see what patty
Jenkins is prepared to bring to the
table
see what gal gadot can do given a new
situation for Wonder Woman
even my the fact that I have never
really cared for Kristen Wiig and
literally anything I've ever seen her
and even that it's not enough to dampen
my insight my excitement for this one
I'm I'm pretty pumped to find out
exactly how this is all gonna go down
after that we've got 10th which is going
to be the new film from Christopher
Nolan because I saw the trailer
it gave me immediate inception vibes and
yes I am down for that because as far as
I'm concerned up to this point inception
is Christopher Nolan's masterpiece a
time you kind of play in that kind of
sandbox again that that feel that sort
of visceral story exploring a
mind-bending concept yes give me that
and then following that one that I
debated having on this list but the
trailer clinched it the king's man now I
had reservations because I loved
Kingsman I'm really kind of hated
Kingsman the Golden Circle this is the
fact that I'm excited for this is me
basically granting Matthew Vaughn a
mulligan this is me giving him a chance
to redeem himself show me that Golden
Circle was a fluke that he still
understands what is good about this
franchise and I think having it set way
in the past removing all the characters
on all the trappings from the first two
which was a big part of what wasn't good
about this thing when it was mired in
the minutiae of the first one without
actually moving things forward or
elevating or even bringing back things
in the right way while eliminating other
stuff that should have been carried
forward it was it was a mess but I think
going back to basics in a story that
doesn't actually contain the characters
that we already know will hopefully
refresh the whole concept and I am
genuinely excited like said it was
clinched by the trailer when that
dropped so after that the movie that
there is no trailer for yet as of time
of recording or if there is I haven't
seen it the trial of Chicago seven and
there's two things that make me excited
for this
it's based off a true and very relevant
story that I think a lot of people kind
of have a vague sense I think people
have heard you know Chicago seven but
like don't know the full deal more
people should and second written and
directed by Aaron Sorkin I'm game
I am definitely game for that after that
this is gonna be a weird one that I like
that I'm excited for this movie given
that I didn't love the previous one but
venom to a bit like Wonder Woman
although Wonder Woman was better than
venom in talking about the first ones
that he's franchise but a bit like that
I really have high hopes they're gonna
they're gonna take the things that
worked in that first one build off of
those and leave behind the things that
didn't work so on the first one like
especially that the marketing that came
out after the movie hit like there was a
trailer and it was like an official
trailer like playing up the sort of
pseudo romance between Eddie and venom I
really hope the new movie leans in I
hope it leans into that dynamic because
the two of them were fantastic and I
want to see it build on its strengths
and drop it and drop its weaknesses
because the first one had a crap villain
and kind of a basic fundamental story
but and he was great his dynamic with
venom was great some of the visuals very
cool and Andy Serkis and the director
you see yeah I want to see this bring it
to the next level and I'm kind of kind
of excited to see what ends up because
if they can just retain the energy of
the first one then it'll still be fun
even if it's not great which is
basically what the first one was so yeah
excited after that we have this one is
actually very strange for me because I
have not seen either of the two films
that directly lead into this godzilla
vs. Kong I haven't seen Godzilla king of
the monsters yet and I still haven't
seen Kong sky Skull Island yet I want to
see both but I'm so excited for this
regardless why because I grew up on the
original King Kong vs. Godzilla and
yes just all day yes give me this I want
it I will just cop to pure nostalgia and
like seven-year-old inner me going so
there's that and one last one and this
is strictly on the strength of the
director doom which is going to be
directed by denis villeneuve hope at him
butcher that too too badly somebody will
tell me if i did somebody will say that
i did even if i didn't so why am i even
bringing up anyways so director of
arrival director of Blade Runner 2049 a
tremendous visual storyteller able to do
so much with setting with structure and
dune as a story is so weird and not
necessarily for a book but for something
to try to adapt to any other medium
which is why Wow it's part of why David
Lynch's dune was such a mess and why the
miniseries could only manage to just be
okay it's the kind of challenge that I
want to see directors like villainy step
up to and he's gonna take a big swing
and maybe you'll be a missed maybe you
will strike out because honestly it's
the kind of challenge I David on paper
David Lynch doing dude that's the kind
of director I want to see stepping up to
that challenge dude didn't work that
time maybe it won't work this time but
man I want to see it because I guarantee
you if nothing else it's gonna be pretty
so that's my list eight films that I am
looking forward to in 2020 that I am
pumped for what are you excited about in
the new year what do you think is gonna
be the things to really look forward to
things I've talked about things I missed
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
bunch of stuff to do down there besides
you know the usuals like subscribe share
our patreon hey link in the description
plus there's links to other things as
well because I got merged and I got a
book and I got all sorts of stuff links
below click on them or don't you don't
have to because end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]